in his new book frontier gavin traveled
to ten countries to find most profitable
investment opportunities his number one
choice is nigeria gavin joins us now
from london
gavin why did nigeria win well the the
book project started off with me asking
the top-performing fund managers those
ones that picked the right countries in
emerging markets during the last five to
ten years which country would be the e/m
the emerging markets growth story of the
future and then i traveled to those
countries with the people that picked
them and then i went back to the group
of fund managers to ask them to rank the
choices of their peers and nigeria came
out number one and mostly that's because
of the demographics of the country if
you think back you know rewind sort of
10-15 years to the origins of the BRICS
growth story Brazil Russia India and
China that was all about these being
large population nations that could
sustain a big consumer boom yeah and the
same thing is for Nigeria this is the
country that according to the UN in our
lifetimes will overtake America's
population to be the third biggest
nation on the planet after India and
China so a huge amount of momentum it's
also a very young population there's got
one of the highest proportions of Under
15's and the base that Nigeria is
starting at this is the country that you
know where there's a lot of subsistence
living there's not a lot of disposable
income generally so there's a big uplift
from there now that's the potential
there's also the risks and we know about
the collapse of the oil price and how
that's devastated Nigeria's agree me we
also know about the violence which has
incurred on the elections Boko Haram in
the north having having killed a lot of
people and so it's not devoid of risks
certainly Gavin one of the things that
development Khanna must say when they
look at the BRICS and also at Nigeria is
that one of the most important factors
is governance not just demographics what
reason do we have for hope that Nigeria
is gonna get this right when Brazil
continues to not get it right well I
mean that's a good point and and
corruption is still what a lot of people
will associate Nigeria with it still
ranks on transparency international
scores
the 40 or so worst countries Buhari the
the new leader
you know most countries that have a new
leader the the new leader is untested in
this case the guy is tested he was a
military dictator during the 80s and
that's not a particularly great record
to look at you know there were all sorts
of cumin rice allegations particularly
going on in that time but he is somebody
who's reputed to live a modest life by
the standards of Nigerian politicians
he's somebody who's made corruption his
number one agenda along with fighting
Boko Haram so this has to be seen but it
certainly from the leadership down there
making the right noises right now
Gavin speaking of Boko Haram how strong
is the extremist group in Nigeria right
now does the military have the capacity
and the will to defeat it well you saw
before the election a six-week campaign
to to make the north clean enough for
voting to happen to wipe out Boko Haram
to the extent that people could actually
get to the polling stations and that was
that was in a way a big success you know
people were very skeptical about why the
election was being delayed for six weeks
they didn't believe that you know after
fighting Boko Haram for six years you
know anything substantial could be
achieved in six weeks but we did see
that roll back the interesting thing
that we're seeing with the fight against
Boko Haram is the neighboring countries
coming together so that Boko Haram
doesn't isn't able to race against the
border to escape when there's a military
offensive